the slap is back will smith is finally
speaking out about that jaw-dropping
oscars moment so what does smith have to
say for himself here's his message to
chris rock
fans were left in shock when king
richard star will smith smacked chris
rock at the oscars in march 2022 after
the comedian made a ball joke at the
expense of smith's wife jada pinkett
smith although the actor finally earned
a statue that night after being
nominated twice his actions led to him
being banned from attending the ceremony
for 10 years social media erupted the
night of the slap with millions chiming
in with their perspectives on the
incident a common consensus was that
smith's actions were at his wife's
request who was shown in footage looking
understandably upset at rock's remarks
now after four months the oscar-winning
actor has finally broken his silence
following this outburst and has claimed
that striking rock was his choice alone
on july 29th smith uploaded a video to
his youtube channel titled it's been a
minute in which he discussed his
behavior at the oscars and answered fans
questions about the event after
revealing that he has not spoken yet to
chris rock at the latter's request the
actor made a direct apology to rock my
behavior
was unacceptable
and i'm here
whenever you're ready to talk smith then
answered the fan question after jada
rolled her eyes she tell you to do
something by assuring viewers i made the
choice on my own from my own experiences
from my history with chris jada had
nothing to do with it smith then
addressed his wife directly saying i'm
sorry babe i want to say sorry to my
kids and my family for the heat that i
brought on all of us smith then
addressed his fellow nominees owning up
to spoiling the night for many of them
explaining this is a community i won
because you voted for me and it really
breaks my heart to have stolen and
tarnished your moment the nomination
smith interrupted was quest love winning
the oscar for the documentary summer of
soul or when the revolution could not be
televised smith said he could still see
the look in quest love's eyes and
apologized to the roots drummer i'm
sorry really isn't
sufficient will smith may have finally
broken his silence on what happened on
oscar night but chris rock is also
telling his side of the story the
comedian is currently touring the
country with kevin hart and during a
performance in new jersey he spoke out
about how the slap impacted him and what
he thought of the entire debacle
according to nbc news rock said that he
wasn't a victim and while it hurt he
still managed to go to work after the
fact he concluded by saying i don't go
to the hospital for a paper cut rock
actually performed shortly after the
incident occurred but he refrained from
talking about the slap at the time he
only briefly alluded to it saying how he
would talk about it at a later time jada
pinkett smith spoke about the incident
back in june on red table talk she hoped
the two could reach some sort of
understanding saying my deepest hope is
that these two intelligent capable men
have an opportunity to heal talk this
out and reconcile brock has yet to
respond to smith's latest apology so
this saga would appear to be ongoing